a mouse is a mouse is a mouse right well
not to PC gamers lights can either make
or break your experience so if you're
not comfortable with your current mouse
or I feels not tracking accurately we
have two new solutions from SteelSeries
for you the rival 310 and the sensei 310
now put both through their paces to
figure out the worse there's $60 price
tag but before we get into how these
mice perform make sure you subscribe to
our channel for more game tech the
sensei 310 and the rival 310 shared ton
of similarities they both have the same
gripping matte body with textured
silicone grips on both sides and the
scroll wheel there are two RGB backlund
zones the SteelSeries logo and the
scroll wheel and both mice have a solid
tactile field for the clicks from their
Omron mechanical switches one notable
feature that these might have over the
old sensei and rival is the true move
three sensor which is said to have
one-to-one tracking up to 3,500 dpi
this means no input gets lost as you
move the mouse there's also jitter
reduction at higher dpi settings so I
can't speak to it that much since I
prefer playing games at lower
sensitivity there are a few important
distinctions the rival is specifically
designed for right-handed users only
with its slight inward curve and
extended surface for a pinky rest it
also has a noticeably higher hunch the
sensei is ambidextrous as it sports a
symmetrical design it also includes four
total side buttons two on each side to
make sure that both left and
right-handed users have access to these
at thumb buttons
this also means that the sensei has two
extra programmable buttons over the
rival it's really convenient to have
although pressing these buttons with
your pinky isn't exactly convenient in a
heated situation and you'll notice that
the side buttons are a little bit
smaller on the sensei technical details
aside both mice feel great to use as
someone who uses a claw grip when
playing games I found both to fit just
right I always go with lightweight mice
and it helps that both the sensei and
rival weigh about 90 grams I would give
a slight edge to the sensei however
mainly because the grooves on both sides
make it easier to lift with my
fingertips now there aren't any
adjustable weights so if you prefer a
heavier Mouse with a more substantial
feel neither of these are going to work
for you when it comes to in
gained performance I found both to
perform flawlessly
I came to this conclusion during my time
with player unknowns battlegrounds and
my favourite competitive shooter Counter
Strike global Offensive after hours of
playing I never really had to think
about my mouth I didn't worry if my
accuracy was a bit off because my sensor
not tracking perfectly or if these mices
organ ah mcc's were throwing off my
ability to aim we all know about the
proverbial blaming of your controls when
you get whooped in a game but you won't
have that excuse with either of these
life
lastly the user-friendly SteelSeries
engine software lets you customize the
RGB lighting adjust the DPI settings and
program each button on these money if I
had to choose between the two I'd go to
the sensei 310 simply based on my
preference for its shape and how it fits
it like Rick and because of the two
additional programmable buttons it has
over the rival 310 but back to that $60
price tag admittedly it's a little feed
from mice with limited features and
physical customization but they're
targeted for those who want to be a bit
more competitive in their games so if
everything I discussed falls in line
with what you want out of a mouse I
suggest you consider these what's your
favourite Mouse you think either of
these from SteelSeries would be a good
fit for you let us know in the comments
subscribe to GameSpot for more game tech
and as always thanks for watching